كريم بنزيما يلحق بكريستيانو رونالدو الى
الدوري السعودي لكره القدم بعد الاعلان
على موافقته على الانتقال الى نادي
الاتحاد بطل الدوري هناك فبينما كانت
الاوساط الرياضيه منشغله على مدار الايام
الماضيه باعلان ريال مدريد المنافس رحيل
المهاجم كريم بنزيما قطع نادي الاتحاد
الشك باليقين واكد انتقال النجم الفرنسي
الى الفريق بعقد يمتد لثلاث سنوات
وتوجد بنزيما مشاهدينا البالغ من العمر 35
عاما بجائزه افضل لاعب في العالم العام
الماضي وكما انه فاز ايضا بخمسه وعشرين
لقبا مع نادي ريال مدريد خلال 14 موسما او
14 موسما بينها خمسه القاب لدوري ابطال
اوروبا
اذا نجوم فازوا بالكره الذهبيه بدا الدوري
السعودي يستقدبهم وبداوا يقتنعون بقوه كره
القدم في المملكه وعلى راس هؤلاء طبعا نجم
النصر والمنتخب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الفائز بالكره الذهبيه في خمس
مناسبات لكن قبل ذلك مشاهدينا الدوري
السعودي ليس بالجديد على نجوم العالم فهو
ايضا يعني شاركت فيه ثلاثه نجوم
برازيليين سبق لهم التتويج بكاس العالم
كلب برازيلي ريفينالو ريفيلين المتوج بكاس
العالم لعام 1970 مع بيليه الذي لعب طبعا
للهلال في الفتره ما بين 1978 و 1981
ملاعب السعوديه احتضنت ايضا برازيلي اخر
توج بكاس العالم وهو ببيتو الفائز
بمونديال 1994 برفقه منتخب بلاده ليلعب
لنادي اتحاد جده عام
2008 البرازيليه الثالث المتوج بكاس
العالم وهو دينيلسون الفائز بمونديال 2002
الذي مثل نادي النصر في موسم 2007 و2006
وبالتالي فان كريم بنزيما سينضم الى قائمه
طويله من النجوم العالميين ممن قصدوا
الدوري السعودي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات